*Musique du début* A travers les époques, les dangers,
*Musique du debut* Une grande aventure les appelles...
C'est...
L'ÉPOPÉE TEMPORELLE !!!!
*Narrateur* : Nos héros sont en terre Maya au milieu d'une végétation luxuriante
et dans une chaleur étouffante
à la recherche du docteur Simon et d'une prétendue relique...
Et comme moultes explorateurs vous le confirmeront, les aventures à l'étranger
commencent bien souvent par un problème ... d'intestins
*bruit de pet*
*Iris* : Thomas !
*Thomas* : C'est pas moi
*Iris* : C'est Eliott peut-être ?
*Eliott* : Je n'ai pas de d’orifice qui permet de produire ce son.
*Iris* : Bon Thomas prend un moment pour toi, nous on t'attend ici.
*Thomas* : Ça vient pas de moi ! Vous savez quoi ça m'énerve ces accusations *pet* j'ai besoin d'un moment tout seul pour *pet*
réfléchir à un plan pour récupérer la relique de ton père juste... *pet* juste derrière les buissons là
*pet*
les buissons de la réflexion. Je reviens.
*Eliott* : Iris, c'est étrange, je ne t'ai jamais vu assouvir ce besoin humain que représente l'évacuation des déchets.
*Iris* : Ouais, parce que je suis une princesse, Eliott.
*Aliénor* : Tenez voici les clefs.
*Iris* Aliénor !
*Iris* : Regarde Thomas y'a ...
Ah oui c'est vrai ! Il fait caca ...
*Aliénor* : Mais vous ne prenez pas les clés ?
Mvous ne prenez pas les clés ? Mais on s'en fout tes clés à la con
*Iris* : Non mais on s'en fout de tes clés à la con !
Tu vois bien qu'on est plus enfermés dans un bateau ?
*Aliénor* : Mais j'essaye d'aider Dame Iris !!!
*Bruit de stupéfaction* Mais où sommes nous désormais ?
Ou sommes nous désormais,quel est cette foret luxurieuse
Quelle est cette forêt luxurieuse ? Est-ce le paradis ?
*Iris* : Bon ! Perdons pas de temps ! Garde tes clés là et donne nous la machine à voyager dans le temps !
*Aliénor soupirant* : Très bien... Si ça peut me permettre de récupérer mon royau... *Bruit de téléportation*
*Iris énervée* : Mais putain il faut toujours qu'elle disparaisse !
*Bruit de foule agitée*
*Eliott* : Iris, tu entends ?
*Iris* : C'est Thomas !
*Eliott* : Je détecte d'autres êtres humains, certainement des Mayas ! Ne nous approchons pas ils sont trop nombreux !
*Iris* : Mais ils sont en train de l'enlever !
*Eliott* : C'est trop dangereux pour le moment.
*Iris paniquée* : On le laisse se faire trucider ?
*Eliott* : On le laisse se faire trucider ?
*Iris* : Non ! Bien-sûr que non !
*Eliott* : Pardon. Je n'avais pas compris que le ton induisait la réponse.
*Iris* : On va à son secours !
*Eliott* : Suivons-les, de loin.
*Musique d'ambiance*
*Thomas* : Heu... Ok... les.. les gars ?
Vous comptez faire quoi avec moi au juste là ? Je sens que c'est important mais j'ai...j'ai un peur je...
Ohh ! Une pyramide, d'accord on va à la pyra.. Ok ! On va à la pyramide.
Putain c'est toujours quand j'ai besoin d'un traducteur robot du futur qu'il y en a jamais ...
Vous allez faire quoi de moi ?
*Eliott* : Regarde Iris ! Ils emmènent Thomas en haut de la pyramide
*Iris* : Oh merde ! Un sacrifice humain !
*Thomas paniqué* : Vous faites quoi ???
*Iris perdue* : Bon bah on le laisse là ... Non non *marmonne*
Non non ! Bon Eliott on s'approche, il faut le sauver !
*Thomas paniqué* : Laissez-moi en vie !
*Eliott* : La cérémonie commence
*Iris terrifiée* : Je peux pas regarder ! Je ferme les yeux c'est trop cruel...
*Eliott* : Ils soulèvent Thomas devant la foule, et le tendent à bout de bras.
*Iris* : J'ai pas fermé les yeux pour que tu me décrives précisément la mort de mon ex !
*Eliott* : Très bien ! *Voix rauque* Mode silencieux activé
*Thomas* : Vous faites quoi là ? Ne faites pas ça !
*Iris* : Oh mon dieu ! Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ? Ils l'ont tué ?
*Thomas* : Non s'il vous plait laissez-moi en vie !
*Eliott* : *Bruit de robot* Fin du mode silencieux. Je décris ou je décris pas ?
*Iris* : Oh tant pis j'ouvre les yeux
*Bruit de foule heureuse* *Cris de joie* *Thomas rigole*
*Thomas* : Arrêtez ! *rires* Arrêtez nan pas sur les côtes !
*Iris* : Ils le chatouillent ?
*Thomas* : Ahhh les cons, les cons ! Vous êtes cons putain !
*Iris* : Ils ont l'air totalement pacifiques en fait !
Allons-y Elliot, on a peut-être une chance !
*Musique*
*Rires de Thomas* Arrêtez oh les cons !
*Un maya* : D'autres étrangers !
*Thomas* : Oh salut les amis ! Ohh arrête de me chatouiller toi !
*Un Maya* : Bienvenue vous voulez des guilis aussi ?
*Iris* :  Ah non non, sans façon. Nous sommes ici pour libérer notre ami Thomas !
*Un Maya* : Il n'est pas prisonnier, on devait juste faire la cérémonie des chatouilles
Maintenant que c'est fait nous avons satisfait les dieux et donc
*Les Mayas en cœur* : CHOCOLAT CHAUD !
*Les Mayas en chantant* : ♫ Même si il fait chaud, il boit son cacao, et pendant qu'il le touille, on lui fait des  chatouilles ! ♫
*Thomas* : Mais il est trop bon votre cacao !
*Eliott*  : Presque aussi bon que mon café ! Je suis preneur de la recette.
*Iris* : Vraiment ? C'est pas vos traditions de faire des sacrifices humains ?
*Un Maya* : Avant oui ! Avant il y a 200 ans nos ancêtres étaient complètement fous
Ils sacrifiaient des vierges pour les dieux, tout ça...
*Un Maya* : Mais entre temps, on a découvert le cacao !
ça nous a tous détendus et maintenant c'est chatouilles et chocolat chaud !
*Un Maya* : Aujourd'hui on est pacifique hein ! C'est fini cette violence hein !
D'ailleurs, comment peut-on vous aider étrangers ?
*Eliott* : Je suis un robot qui vient du futur et voici Thomas du XXème siècle
Nous sommes ici pour chercher une relique que l'inventeur de la machine à voyager dans le temps vous à sûrement confié.
*Iris* Chtt, Nan ! Mais nan ! Fallait pas tout dire comme ça !
*Un Maya* Ah oui je vois d'accord.
*Eliott* Mais ? Vous, vous, nous croyez ?
*Un Maya* Oh ben on croit déjà une bonne trentaine de dieux dont, le dieu chasseur d'opposum !
Alors des gens qui voyagent dans le temps franchement c'est pas dingue.
D'ailleurs on a eu la visite d'un dieu blanc pas plus tard que ce matin !
*Iris* Ah super ! C'est mon père ! Menez-nous à lui.
*Un Maya* Non, car il a disparu comme par magie ! Il nous a donné une relique à protéger comme la prunelle de nos yeux.
On l'a enfoui sous le temple, avec des pièges, des gardes, des caïmans. On adore les caïmans.
*Un maya* Oh ! Regardez là bas ! Des nouveaux visiteurs !
*Foule* : Youpi !
Ils arrivent dans des énormes bateaux !
Préparez du cacao pour les visiteurs !
*Foule* : Cacao ! Cacao !
*Eliott* : Ceux qu'ils appellent visiteurs semblent être des conquistadors.
*Thomas* : Cool !
*Iris, sarcastique* : Ils vont nous massacrer et s'emparer du pays ...
*Thomas* : Euh ... pas cool ...
*Maya* : Ouah ! Comment ils sont beaux les nouveaux visiteurs..
Assis sur leurs chiens géants et tout..
*Un maya* : Oh la la !  T'as vu ?! Ils ont des bâtons qui font du bruits et des éclairs !
*Maya* : Regarde Cappou !
*Iris* : Des cavaliers avec des fusils ?!
*Maya* : Rooh, comme c'est original !
*Iris* : Amis Mayas ! Ces hommes sont mauvais et dangereux !
Ils sont là pour s'emparer de vos terres !
*Maya* : Mais nooon ! Ça va ! Soyez pas parano comme ça !
Descendons les accueillir ! Vite ! Le cacao et les gaufrettes !
*Joie de la foule*
Visiteurs ! Voici du cacao et des petites gaufrettes croustillantes super bonnes ! Tiens, régale-toi !
*Conquistador* : Holà ! Soy el capitaine Fernandez !
Et par ce drapeau
Je déclare ce pays ... colonie du royaume d'Espagne !
*Thomas*: Pardon ? Qu'est-ce.. qu'est quoi ?
*Iris* : C'est cool la traduction mais c'est obligé l'accent pourri ?
*Eliott* : Je n'aime pas cet homme. Je lui fais un accent pourri.
*Fernandez* : Emparez vous de leurs otages !
*Iris* : Quoi ?!
*Thomas* : Oh putain !
*Les personnages se débattent. La foule en panique*
*Fernandez* : Ligotez les prisonniers ! Et tuez-les !
*Thomas* : Noooon  !
*Fernandez* : Pas de survivants !
*Iris* : C'est un massacre !
*Maya* : Adieu Cappou !
*Cappou* : Adieu Chino !
*Thomas* : Attendez ... Vous vous appelez Cappou et Chino ?
*Bruits électroniques*
*Eliott* : Un cappuccino ! Combien de sucres ?
*Iris* : On vous l'avait dit ! Ils vont nous massacrer !
*Thomas* : Iris ... Avant de mourir ... Je voulais te dire que mes sentiments pour toi ...
*Hurlements de brute*
*Iris, Thomas, Elliot* : La Buse ?!
*Cappou* : C'est qui lui ?
*Iris* : On l'avait oublié !
*Chino* : Ah mais il nous aide !
*Fernandez* : Ma..ma..ma..mais ¿qué pasa ?
*La Buse* : On fait la compote !
*Cappou* : Merci ! Merci, quelle force !
*Thomas* : Lui, défonce-le...non pas lui c'est un Maya ! ah...trop tard, c'est pas grave
*Iris* : Vas-y La Buse !
*Thomas* : Un dernier La Buse !
*Fernandez* : Non...pas moi ! Je suis le capitaine Fernandez
*bruit de hache* *Fernandez* : Non...pitié !
*La buse* : Tiens prends-ça !
*Foule* : Yeah !!! Il nous a sauvés !
*La buse* J'adore ce voyage
*Thomas* : Bien joué La Buse
*Iris* : Oh merci tu nous as sauvés. Sans toi c'était la fin !
*La buse* : C'est bizarre ce qui s'est passé.
*La buse* : J'avais ni envie de vous demander de l'argent ni envie de vous tuer...
*La buse* : Juste envie de vous aider...
*Thomas* : Ah ça la buse c'est parce qu'on est devenus... des amis
*La buse* : Des... amis ?
*Iris* : Mais, où t'étais la buse ?
*La buse* : Oh, mes desamis j'ai vécu une aventure incroyable !
Je suis parti à la recherche d'un trésor
J'ai vu ce temple [*Un maya* : la pyramide] Ouais ça ! J'suis entré d'dans et puis je suivi mon instinct d'pirate
il y avait des énigmes à résoudre genre deux statues presque identiques mais qui pouvaient bouger
il semble qu'il fallait faire une combinaison de mouvements  [*Thomas* : ouais et alors ?] j'ai tout cassé
puis je suis passé ! [*Un maya* : Oh non, il a cassé nos pièges !] Après il y avait un long corridor,
il manquait des dalles et il y avait des flèches empoisonnées qui sortait des murs,
et semblait qu'il y avait un chemin précis à suivre...
*Thomas* : ouais et alors ?
*La Buse, enjoué* J'ai tout cassé !
Les murs, les flèches, les dalles, le chemin : tout cassé !
puis enfin je suis arrivé devant une porte en métal forgé,
avec des tas de chiffres on aurait dit une suite de nombres !
*Iris* : Et t'as tout cassé.
*La Buse* : Non ! J'ai remis les chiffres dans un ordre précis !
C'était la suite de Fibonacci !
quelqu'un me l'avait expliqué avant que j'le tue... *petit rire*
*Iris* : Mais ça veut dire que t'as trouvé la relique de mon père !
Enfin...le trésor !
*La Buse* : Ouais, le v'là ! C'est un truc en bois roux qui coulisse avec plein de bidules écrit dessus...
Pas dingue !
*Iris* Oh j'me souviens de ça ! C'était un jouet que j'avais quand j'étais petite,
c'est un calendrier rond que mon père m'avait donné  pour apprendre le système solaire !
*Thomas* : Est-ce qu'on s'en irait pas parce qu'il y a les cavaliers qui débarquent encore !
*Iris* : Eliott dis-moi qu'il y a un indice sur cet objet !
*Eliott* : D'après mes capteurs le calendrier possède une balise donnant des coordonnées temporelles divisées en trois parties,
il nous manque deux balises.
*Iris* : Et où est-ce qu'on trouve ça nous ? Vite Eliott ! Les conquistadors ne sont plus très loin !
*Eliott* : C'est bon, mes calculs m'indiquent où se trouve la seconde balise.
*Iris* : Yes ! Eliott, tu déchires !
*Eliott* : On peut de s'y rendre maintenant.
*La Buse* : J'viens avec vous les desamis !
*Iris* : La Buse, je pense que ta force sera plus utile aux Mayas qui vont devoir affronter les conquistadors.
*Eliott* : Notre destination semble très dangereuse. Une aide puissante ne serait pas de refus.
*Iris* : Bon d'accord, la Buse tu viens avec nous !
*Eliott* : Coordonnées entrées.
*Iris* : Mes amis Mayas, je ne vous cache pas que les prochaines semaines risquent d'être difficiles,
Alors tenez bon, okay ?
*Les mayas* : Vous inquiétez pas ! On va faire ce qu'on sait faire de mieux...
♫ On fait des
guilis et ça nous réussit ! Les dieux sont ravis et on se fait des amis ♫
*Iris* : Okay. Et juste comme ça, hein, s'ils vous offrent des couvertures, refusez-les.
*Eliott* : Retemporalisation immédiate
*Iris* : Allez, salut !
*Voyage temporel*
*Narrateur* : Le saviez-vous ?
Les envahisseurs européens n'ont pas hésité à donner des couvertures contaminées par la petite vérole,
pour décimer les populations
d'Amérique.
L'Épopée Temporelle, ce n'est pas que du divertissement c'est aussi de la culture,
sauf les petites gaufrettes ! Ça, les Mayas ils n'en avaient pas !
À la semaine prochaine pour découvrir leur nouvelle destination !
Merci d'avoir écouté le sixième épisode de l'Épopée Temporelle, n'hésite pas à t'abonner et à mettre un pouce en l'air,
Et à la semaine prochaine ! #Jambon